has our industry in the five years that
you've struggled through it to get where
you are
do you see meaningful change that makes
you hopeful
for the future i see it on the horizon
i think that the first four or so years
no
and it was very true and it's it's it
still needs a lot of work i see it on
the horizon maybe not be
from the inside but from from the people
who have been oppressed
just making it so and making it
undeniable
um and the way that i kind of say that
you say that i
i did break in that is a terrible way of
saying it but think about it i
put i am not um i'm an outlier
and i have a way of thinking that most
people don't have and i have a a a
a like a a way of doing things that most
people don't have and shouldn't
in most in most cases um this is like a
this is insanity what i've done it's
insanity work right
this shouldn't have to be this hard to
get this far
so that's where i say so i did break in
but i was i tell you what
if we all had to do what i had to do it
wouldn't be worth it not sustainable not
worth it sleeping in the airport
so the lesson is even though i threaded
the needle
that doesn't mean that the problem is
solved don't look at my success and say
mission accomplished because the mission
hasn't been accomplished
right and we we even see it with
successful founders um uh
was it angela benton who did the tweet
storm recently
about she had a bad experience with
cowboy ventures and it was just that
they
oh really no i didn't hear about that
yeah she tweeted about it and she was
just like you know the
i went to the first meeting was great
the second meeting like
uh uh i guess it was ted wang was the
person she was talking about
and he was kind of like okay next slide
next slide i get it i get it again it
was kind of dismissive right so it
wasn't the
uh you know we're not investing in this
kind of thing it was more like a little
bit of a subtle
she felt bias i wouldn't necessarily
say racism there's a bias as a prejudice
those are all bad things too
yeah and so it's like this bias and she
also respect
right which i think is like a very
interesting word because there's like
outright racism there's bias
and there's just like being respectful
during a meeting with the founder
and like using your brain like if you've
dedicated the 30 minutes like just give
them the 20 minutes to
talk and then ask a couple questions
you're good you don't have to rush them
through the deck and
you know um she didn't wind up feeling
very good about it but that's good that
you feel like we've made progress
but still a ways to go and the change
will be from outside yeah i think
there's there's more work to do
a hundred percent more work to do we are
we're just getting started
but if i didn't feel hopeful i wouldn't
be able to wake up every morning and
work on this
there's just no way yeah and on that
note i'll just say
it's good to know you arlen it's good to
know your story and to watch you do it
um and it's good to know you're waking
up every day doing the hard work for the
founders
who need you right yeah and uh you have
my respect
and uh my support uh you know that um
and uh can't wait to share some deal
flow as well yeah you get going
everybody you hear my voice stop what
you're doing
i want you to do three things number one
you go to backstage crowd you sign up
credit or not number two you buy the
goddamn book your cheapskates
buy the book right now she couldn't go
on book tour because of corona
unfortunately uh but when you do your
book tour let me know if you need a
an interview or something like that i'm
happy to help i'll have some tips for
you too on that
uh on the book tour i'll give it to you
though privately um
so that's number two about the book uh
number three sign up for the podcast
where you know
sometimes on a sunday night she may drop
something raw
and entertaining uh your first million
is the name of the podcast
arlen is uh arlen was here and she's
still here
i can tell you based on my experience
she ain't going anywhere we'll see you
next time on this week in startups bye
bye everybody